So here is my truth table of these eight different outcomes.
The ones that has head exactly once are this one, this one, and this one,
but they're not all equally likely.
Heads, heads, heads is much more likely than say tails, tails, tails
because heads has a probability of 0.8^3.
This one here has an outcome probability of 0.8³ while this one has an outcome probability of 0.2^3.
All of the green ones have the same outcome probability.
They all have exactly one head 0.8 and two tails.
So as before, we took the probability to be one of these heads in the truth table.
This time each of those has a probability of 0.032. That's each one of the three.
Now, we have to consider all of these three outcomes, which means you're going to add 0.032
for each one of those three guys over here and this gives me as an answer 0.096.
That's a nontrivial question.